اجعله يتصل بالشرطة نيابة عنك
الخروج من هناك أنت تفعل أنت
تظهر بعض التصوف الثالث هناك
إنه تبشير أنت جيد
مثل هذا في أي وقت لديك هنا
لا يسمح بارتداء مثل هذا
إنها مدرسة مهنية لك
لا أملك
لا ينظر إلي هكذا إذا كنت
الرجاء خفض الناس لأن نعم
لأنك تعرف ماذا في الزي
مثل هذا عادة ما تمشي ثلاثة
لا وراء الرجال بخفض
عيون وهناك تفعل الدليل
للتعديل
[موسيقى]
ليس لدي مقبول حتى هنا ما
ما الذي سنفعله أنت ذاهب إلى المنزل
يمكنك التغيير
أعود إلى المدرسة بملابس متواضعة
من فضلك وهذه ليست مهمتك
هي صديق
[موسيقى]
خلال المقابلة استمرت حوالي 15
دقائق لي أنا رد فعل لأخذ بلدي
الهاتف والتصوير لأنني
علمت أنها ستكون سيئة للغاية
شعرت أنه شعرت
في منزلي وفي الواقع ستبدأ
قل
يقترح لكنه تحرك بفرط فينا
يتهمنا الاتهام
التوظيف لم أكن أعرف حتى ماذا
كانت كلمة النبوية قبل هذا
اراك هناك
[موسيقى]
أنا
أنا لا أبكي أمام الناس لذلك أنا
لا أخاف أن أراها ، لم أرغب في ذلك
تعطي هذه المتعة ولكن على أي حال
بكت مباشرة مع أ
دموع في العيون نسمعها في الفيديو
في 30 و 20